so sustainable development as defined by
the world Commission is development that
meets the needs of the present while not
compromising the ability of future
generations to meet their needs as I've
pointed out in economics that's a very
simple concept that means well fish does
not decline over time and that in turn
requires managing a portfolio of assets
for the economy which doesn't include
just reproducible fixed capital but also
cumin capital and now natural capital
which also includes ecosystems as
capital that should be straightforward
right well at this point I think
economists kind of diverge however the
strong sustainability argument suggests
the problem is that not all forms of
capital in our portfolio for our economy
are equally substitutable for each other
in particular some forms of natural
capital should be kept intact because
there we have not found a way of
substituting for them if we'd lose or
destroy them once we lose those natural
capital it's irreversible and in any
case we don't really know the value
we've never have known the value and we
still don't know the value and we
probably will never guess the future
value so the argument goes is that we
can call that form of this natural
capital is essential natural capital and
we should keep it intact or as much as
possible just in a nutshell the week
versus strong sustainability argument
the weak sustainability argument is
there's no difference between natural
and other forms of capital and as long
as the pleated natural capital is
replaced with even more valuable
physical and human capital then the
value of our overall portfolio is going
to increase and what we need to do to a
chain and attain sustainability is to
maintain enhance the value of the
aggregate
stock the whole portfolio strong
sustainability says we can't view the
whole portfolio as a homogeneous stock
in fact we can't always substitute for
natural capital as uncertainty over
current and future values particularly
the vet Claude school goods and services
unique environments in biodiversity
meaning that some natural capital is
always going to be essential and cannot
be replaced so sustainability requires
maintaining enhancing the value of the
aggregate capital stock that's true but
it will also require preserving some
essential natural capital if global
policy makers are truly willing to break
the vicious cycle of unsustainable
development then we've got to address
the current global shortfall and echo
system conservation I think many
countries could raise the money through
their own national means particularly
the more rich and rapidly developing and
industrializing countries but there's
many other countries of the world in
many other regions within countries of
the world which desperately need
assistance and we're talking about
global benefits here benefits today and
in the future we have to deal with it I
think potential biggest breakthrough and
hope might be through a currency
transaction tax or financial transaction
tax I talked about that in my paper and
I actually think perversely the time to
do it is now because as Stephanie
griffith-jones argued improving the net
contribution of the financial sector to
the real economy into the welfare of
ordinary people would significantly
rehabilitate the financial sectors
battered image which should be a
desirable aim of that sector itself